-To moderate this
panel, I'd like
to introduce Dr. Christine
Seidman, the Smith
Professor of Medicine
and Professor of Genetics
at Harvard Medical School
and Howard Hughes Medical
Institute.
She is also at Brigham Women's
Hospital, where I'm from,
and she's the founding director
of the Cardiovascular Genetics
program there.
She's also run the Brigham
Research Institute.
Directed that, as well.
She's a distinguished
scientist of the American Heart
Association and a
member of the Institute
of Medicine at the National
Academies of Science.
Please welcome
Christine Seidman.
-Well, thank you.
I am delighted to be here.
I have enjoyed the
talk so far today.
And I know that now
that you've seen
the ancient past, the
problems in ethical
and complexities that DNA
science can elicit, both at law
and society as well
as ethical regions,
it's time to assume
we've got that covered
and jump into the future.
So we're going to have
three fabulous talks
today from the individuals
in front of you.
I want to introduce
them very briefly.
Their detailed biographies
are in your programs.
Jacob Corn is going to tell
us about new approaches
to modulate DNA sequences,
in particular focusing
on Cas CRISPR Professor Corn
is at the Innovative Genomic
Institute in the
Department of Molecular
and Cell Biology at the
University of Berkeley,
in California.
We're going to hear from
a fabulous practitioner,
professor, and physician,
Alison Murdoch.
She is the head
of the Department
of Reproductive Medicine
of Newcastle University,
in the United Kingdom.
And we're going to hear
from Floyd Romesberg.
And he will tell
you that GATK, which
are the nucleotide--
single-letter designations
of the nuclei-- are not
all the code that's there.
So he's going to tell us about x
and y that follows up on those.
So we're looking forward
to each of these talks.
Each of our presenters
will come up and give us
several minutes of information
about their particular fields
and expertise.
And then we're going to
have the opportunity to have
a verbal discussion amongst
us, here, and very much,
as you've seen before,
involving all of you.
So warm up your questions,
and welcome to the future.
We'll start, first
of all, with Jacob.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
-So, first off, thanks very
much for the invitation.
It's really fantastic.
I've had a great day, listening
to the talks and the discussion
so far.
I want to start off by asking--
this might be a little strange
ask this, here, in Boston.
But who has ever
heard of CRISPR Cas9?
I sort of expected all of
those hands, given this.
That's sort of universal.
Right?
I've asked undergraduates this.
I've asked high-schoolers this.
People are hearing about
this, and it's in the news.
So what I want to
talk about today
is the genome-editing
revolution.
And I sort of want to maybe
distract some of the people
in the audience by starting
off by passing this around.
This is the thing that
has everybody excited.
This is a 3D model of Cas9 in
the act of actually editing
DNA.
It has the RNA that's
guiding it around.
Just feel free to
pass that around.
Rather than nodding
off during the talk,
now you have an excuse to pay
attention to something else.
-Was it color codes?
-Color codes.
-Oh, sorry.
The color codes.
The orange is the guide RNA.
In fact, this model comes apart.
And so you can take the top off,
and you can see the guide RNA
wrapping around the target DNA
and illustrating to you how
it actually recognizes DNA.
This type of model is
actually very useful.
This is something that
is not just like a toy.
I use this for education
in the classroom.
But we also printed this to
try to understand something
about how the enzyme works.
So it turns out
the enzyme is not
in a productive confirmation.
One of the active
sites is pointing
in the wrong direction.
It's not clear why that is--
what the actual confirmation is
going to be.
But just from
looking at the model,
not even looking
at it on a screen--
a computer screen-- just
looking from the physical model,
you can see this thing.
And so it highlights neat,
interesting questions.
So what I want to
talk about today is
the fact that we're really good,
at this point, at reading DNA.
We're very fast at it.
This guy looks incredibly wise.
I might argue that
we're not necessarily
all that wise about
what's in our genomes.
But we're at least able
to speed-read our genomes,
at this point.
And we're learning a lot.
We're learning very quickly.
And,
Thanks to work
that's been happening
over the last couple of
years, maybe the last 20
years, and now things have
started to really take off,
we're starting to be
able to write in genomes.
And, at this point, we're
still kind of tinkering around.
So there's been this
huge democratization
of gene editing.
And we're still
learning how to do it,
but a lot more
people are doing it.
To compare what I mean by
"reading" and "writing" DNA,
I just want to
compare our ability
to synthesize the genetic
sequence with our ability
to read genetic sequence and
compare that to something
called "Moore's law."
You guys have probably
heard of Moore's law.
It's the speed with which
computers increase in speed.
So this is a log scale.
And this, here, is how
computers increase in speeds.
So you can see it's basically
linear in log scale.
And sequencing looks like this.
It kind of follows Moore's law,
and then next-gen sequencing
comes around, and just explodes.
Right?
Suddenly we're able
to read whole genomes.
It's relatively trivial.
We have a MiSeq in the lab.
Those things-- I mean, they
run 20 million bases at a time,
and it takes eight hours to
run one of those experiments.
OK?
So it's huge amounts of data.
It's really exciting to
have that capability.
And this is kind of where
synthesizing DNA goes.
OK?
The next important
part of the equation
is how cheap
sequencing has gotten.
So this is the cost
of DNA sequencing.
And you see that, as
speed has increased,
it's just plummeted
through the floor.
And the same thing
has not happened
to our ability to rewrite DNA--
the ability to make sequences.
So I sort of make this akin
to-- we have this giant library
in front of us.
And now we're able to
go through and we're
able to read this
entire library.
And it's not necessarily
as simple as this.
But let's say we have
something in there, right?
We would be able to
find that sequence-- be
able to find that word.
And what genome editing
is really all about
is adding the Find/Replace of
Word on top of that library.
OK?
We want to be able
to say, there's
something wrong in this library.
Right?
Maybe someone has cancer, and
we want them to be a dancer.
And let's replace that C. OK?
So, what is gene editing?
Gene editing comes
down to our ability
to use tools and change
genetic sequence.
And the way that we've
done that in the past
are two technologies.
So in the '90s, so-called
zinc-finger nucleases
were invented.
These are protein-based
recognition modules.
So you're using proteins
to recognize DNA.
And so you have to
reprogram the protein.
And it's very hard, and
it takes a lot of work,
but a couple of companies
and a couple of people
got quite good at it.
It takes about $3,000 and 10 to
12 weeks to make one of these.
So it's not super paralyzable,
but you can do it.
And so this really
remains sort of something
that a couple of people would
do and a couple of people
would be good at, but you'd
have to collaborate with them,
if you'd want to do
that kind of thing.
Then in 2009 came TAL
effector nucleases.
These were a bit more modular.
So each protein
module recognized
one set of base pairs.
And so you could
stack them together.
They ended up being a little
tricky to make, sometimes,
but people got
quite good at them.
They were able to automate
that kind of synthesis.
And it seemed to
work pretty well.
TALENs are actually quite good.
However, I sort of feel
bad for the people that
invested a lot of
time in TALENs,
because what came along
only three years later
was this thing
called CRISPR/Cas9.
So there's still reasons to
use TALENs and still reasons
to using fingers, and there are
all these kinds of, you know,
compare/contrast articles
that people read and write.
And I think what's really
important is we have a toolbox
now.
Right?
And we used to have one tool,
and then we had two tools,
and now we have three tools,
and they're all very good,
and they all have
their purposes.
And so I think this
is-- as you'll see,
it's the start of an upward
trend in genome editing,
in general.
So what CRISPR/Cas9
is it's a protein,
it holds onto a
piece of RNA, and it
uses that RNA to make a cut.
And since it's
using DNA-- that is,
DNA that gets made into an
RNA-- to do the recognition,
it's very cheap,
and it's very fast,
and it's very easy
to reprogram this.
To give you an idea of
how fast, cheap, and easy,
at this point we typically
have undergraduates
who are learning how
to do PCR prepare
some of this
genome-targeting reagents.
So people that have never
touched a pipette before,
they learn how to
do it by making
genome-targeting
reagents for other people
in the lab to do
genome-targeting experiments.
So I think it's really
important to stress
where CRISPR/Cas9 comes
from, because it's
sort of this crazy tool.
And you might want to ask, well,
how did such a thing exist?
At its heart, Cas9 stems from
bacterial immune systems.
And these are called "CRISPRs."
CRISPR stands for Cluster
of Regularly Interspaced
Palindromic Repeats.
And that's because you have
these things called CRISPR loci
that sit in bacteria.
Where do they come from?
When a virus infects
a bacteria-- that
is, when a bacteria
gets the flu--
it's injecting into
DNA into the bacteria.
And the bacteria needs to
do something about that,
because it may have some
negative consequence.
And so it's developed
machinery to take
bits of the viral genome
and incorporate it
into its own genome.
And people first
discovered CRISPR arrays
when they started noticing
that parts of bacterial genomes
were exactly the same as
small parts of viral genomes.
And it turns out
that what happens
is the bacteria then
makes RNA off of this.
So it incorporates
into the CRISPR array
through a process
called "adaptation."
It then makes RNA
off of the array.
That gets separated into
these so-called "crRNAs."
Remember, these crRNAs are
now RNAs that stemmed back
from this original sequence.
Cas proteins, of which
Cas9 is one of them,
recognize those RNAs and
use them to guide back.
So they complete the circle.
So you start with
viral DNA, and you
have to find some way
to rerecognize that.
And what the Cas proteins do
is they then cut at that site.
And the really fundamental
recognition, here,
is that this doesn't
have to be viral DNA.
You can program these with any
kind of RNA to cut anything.
So let's zoom in a little
bit into how this works.
Cas9 is monomeric protein.
It has an RNA that it binds.
So there's a little
constant region.
And then there's one
little bit that you vary.
And this can be 20 bases
or so-- 18 to 20 bases.
And we call it
the "protospacer."
And all you have to do is
know that A goes with T
and G goes with C. And you
can then program it to bind
and then cut anywhere
in the genome.
So you just take
this constant region,
and you add any
protospacer that you want,
and Cas9 will cut there,
so long as-- there's
only one restriction--
there's a short sequence,
here, called a "protospacer
adjacent motif" also
in that genome.
For some organisms
that make Cas9,
this ends up being three bases.
For others, it's a
little bit longer.
They're now a couple
of different enzymes
that have different
requirements.
But that means, again, that
our toolbox is getting larger.
We can target more and
more and more sequence.
Cas9 then makes a
double-stranded cut
and has two active sites.
And so it cuts both
of those places.
So it's very easily
reprogrammed.
And we can target it using
simple rules of base pairing.
If the model hasn't
gone around you yet,
this is what it looks like in
3D space, rather than a cartoon.
There's a guide
RNA, and it's really
wrapped around the molecule.
There's a duplex of DNA,
coming in on either side, which
gets separated.
If we take off that
one bit, you can
see the RNA itself is wrapped
all the way around the DNA.
OK?
And something-- we
still don't quite
know what it is--
something tells Cas9,
once it's made all the
wraps, I need to cut now.
And these--
Again, this is a
very emerging field.
We still don't know
what triggers it to cut.
You can make Cas9s that go
to a place and do nothing,
and they don't cut.
So there's still a lot of
mysteries to be worked out.
Once you've made the
cut, you get editing.
Right?
But Cas9-- I really want
to stress this-- Cas9
is not the thing
doing the editing.
In terms of zinc fingers,
TALENs, and Cas9,
all Cas9 does is make
a double-stranded cut
inside the genome.
And it turns out that
the host genome--
the thing that you
put it into-- is
taking care of the repair,
which does the edit.
And so, if you make
edits in human cells,
if you make edits in model
species, like Drosophila,
it's their cells that are
actually doing the edit.
And that's because there are
a couple of different pathways
to repair double-strand
breaks in cells.
Cells really care about
having a double-strand break.
You can imagine that, if you
get a double-strand break
in your cell, that's
not a good thing.
You need to somehow get
those pieces back together.
And so there are all kinds
of break-repair machinery
in your cells.
There's one, which is
dominant, called NHEJ.
This is an error-prone process.
So if you make a double-strand
break, at that point
you get variable-length
so-called indels,
or insertions or deletions.
As you might
expect, this kind of
screws up the sequence
that is in there.
And so this makes what
we call "knockout."
Think of this as, like, a sword
that you're going to go in
and chop it into a gene.
And you might do
this, when you want
to say, what does this gene do?
This is a very classic
thing in biology.
You want to know what a gene
does, so you take a model
system and you break
that gene and say,
what happened after I broke it?
One thing that has a lot
of people very excited,
though, is so-called
Homology-Directed Repair,
or HDR.
This is where you make the
cut and you provide a donor.
And this donor has
a different sequence
than what was in there before.
The cell then incorporates that.
These dashed arrows are meant
to say we actually don't
know what's going on here.
There's some emerging
data, maybe a little bit
of which I'll talk
about, suggesting
that this is not what people
classically think of as HR.
But what this does is
it does precise editing.
So instead of
disrupting what's there,
you're able to very precisely
flip in certain sequences.
The problem is, this happens
at much lower efficiency
than knockout.
And so this is
something that lets
you test what does
this gene do and may
be applicable in some
therapeutic cases.
But, in any case where
you saw, say, this person
had a disease that was caused
by certain mutation-- maybe
they had a severe
combined immunodeficiency.
And we'll talk about so-called
"autologous bone-marrow
transplant."
If you wanted to
correct that and then
transplant edited
stuff back into them,
you'd have to make an edit.
OK?
So this is useful for asking,
what does this very specific
part do?
What do these specific bases do?
And can we cure diseases?
Now it turns out that Cas9 can
be adopted to do other things.
So if you take the active
sites and you mutate them,
at that point Cas9 is going to
different parts of the genome,
but it's not cutting them.
And so people then take
different so-called "effector
proteins," and they
attach them to them.
Why would you want to do this?
Well, your genes are making RNA.
And those RNAs are
making protein.
And so, if you attach
various effectors that
will either turn on or
turn off transcription,
making of the RNA,
it turns out that you
can increase or decrease the
amount of protein that is made
from certain genes-- in situ.
So you don't have to be
adding something extra in.
You're making extra protein
from the endogenous context.
And this ends up actually
being like a rheostat.
You can tune this.
So it's a matter of not
just coming in with a sword
or coming in with a scalpel.
You're going to say, I'm
going to turn this gene up,
or I'm going to turn this
gene down, and figure out what
dosage does, in this system.
But I think probably
what most people
have heard about,
for gene editing,
is its ability to maybe
be therapeutic someday.
And so I wanted to
talk about what might
be possible in the near term.
So, at this point, we're not
talking about germ-line editing
or anything like that.
I share some of
the thoughts about,
is that really going to do
something in the short term?
In the short term, what
we're talking about
is so-called
"hematopoietic" diseases.
These are diseases
of the blood system.
And so this is cases
where, right now,
if someone has a
bone-marrow disease,
you might take a
healthy donor and do
a so-called
"allogeneic" transplant
into the person
with the disease.
You'd have to get rid
of the bone marrow.
And that would then
cure the disease.
OK?
So the bone marrow has
some mutation in it.
Maybe it's making
sickle hemoglobin,
maybe it's not
making B or T cells.
And so you ablate
the bad bone marrow
and put in healthy bone
marrow from the donor.
This has a couple
of complications.
There's graft-versus-host
disease,
people have to be on
immunosuppressants,
and so it has problems.
But it works, and
it works very well
and provides a really
good proof of concept
for the next, which is so-called
"autologous" transplant.
So when people talk
about gene editing
for hematopoietic
disease, we're actually
talking about something
that might not
be that far in the future.
Because here we don't
have to worry about,
like, how are we going
to edit a tissue?
Like, someone with
muscular dystrophy--
how do we get it into
the bone, or how do we
get into the muscle?
We're talking about
doing something
pretty similar to what
I just told you about.
Instead of taking bone marrow
from an unaffected person,
we're going to take bone marrow
from the affected person,
correct that gene, and then just
put it right back into there.
And that would be
just as curative
as taking from a
different person.
But there's no
host-versus-graft.
You are your own donor.
There's an unlimited
number of donors,
because you are your own donor.
You don't have to
worry about matching.
And so this is, I think,
why people are really
excited about this possibility.
Right?
We're already doing
this, except we
have the dangers of taking
bone marrow from other people.
We just want to be able to
take from the same person.
Now there are, of course,
a lot of safety concerns.
How specific are the reagents?
How are we going to achieve
the right amounts of editing?
What are the right
amounts of editing?
I think these are
very open questions.
There's a lot of work going
on by very smart people.
And well get answers to
those hopefully soon.
I wanted to point out that
gene editing is not just
for genetic disease.
For curing genetic disease.
People can use it
in research cases,
say, to model cancer in vivo.
People have shown that you
can edit primary human T
cells to try to figure
out immune function.
And people have also sort
of turned this on its head.
Instead of having
bacteria-killing viruses
through CRISPR, they
actually had phage viruses
killing bacteria using CRISPR.
So some people have made
actually pretty good
antibacterials out of this.
So there's a lot of
different things you can do.
I think that that brings up one
other really important point,
which is it seems-- so
far, at least-- Cas9
is very generally applicable.
So it works in bacteria,
it works in yeast,
it works in flies,
it works in worms.
It works in a lot of
different model systems.
Sort of presaging some of the
things that we've heard about.
And maybe the end of my
talk-- relatively recently,
people showed that
it works in monkeys.
And that should give you
a hint of what's coming
and the types of discussions
that people are having.
It works in a variety of
agricultural crops-- wheat,
rice, sorghum, maize--
all kinds of things.
And it works in human cells.
One thing that I think is really
exciting, though, in terms
of working in nonhuman
systems, is that Cas9 also
works in nonmodel organisms.
Nonmodel organisms are so called
because maybe you have trouble
growing them in the lab.
But one other reason
something might
be a nonmodel organism is that
it so-called, quote-unquote,
"has no genetics."
Right?
Maybe you've
sequenced the genome,
you kind of know
where genes are,
you don't have any way
to do anything with them,
to figure out what
those genes are.
And people have now shown that,
for example, cyanobacteria,
mosquitoes, butterflies,
goats, cows,
chickens can all be
edited using Cas9.
And I think this is
really important,
because instead of
now learning something
about life and about the world
by looking at these few model
organisms-- right?
--flies, worms--
we can look at almost anything.
There's someone in my department
who works on this really--
I can't even remember the name.
It's this crazy
little crustacean.
No one else in the
world works on it.
But it turns out that it does
limb regeneration like crazy.
Right?
You can cut off any of its
limbs, and it'll grow back.
And no one knows why,
because they don't have
any kind of genetics for it.
And so he put Cas9 into
it, and he ejected it.
He targeted this thing
called a "Hox gene" that
does body patterning,
and he found out
that he can make
antennae instead of limbs
for those particular regions.
And those antennae
will regenerate, too.
So there's something that's
controlling regeneration
of this body part.
It opens up huge
amounts of questions
that you can ask on a
very fundamental level.
So I think it's really
transformative, not just
in the way that I think
people have been stressing,
in terms of health
and cell biology,
but also just our basic,
fundamental understanding
of what makes life life--
what makes an organism
an organism, how do
organisms develop.
And I think that is
really the one take-home
that I'd like everybody
to take from this, which
is that, in the
past gene editing
was about systems that were
relatively difficult to use--
relatively specialized.
And so a lot of different
people would have ideas,
and they would have to
funnel through people
that were gene editors.
OK?
And that produced
kind of a blockade
in the types of questions
that you would ask.
Whereas what Cas9 seems to be
doing-- it's very inclusive.
Almost anyone can
get it to work.
There have been courses,
here, on the East Coast.
We've run courses at the
IGI, just teaching people
how to do this stuff.
We've put protocols online.
There are all sorts of freely
available reagents for helping
people do this stuff.
And I think that's led to a
very inclusive technology,
so that, when you
have a question,
you can ask and answer
that question yourself.
And it's hugely accelerated
the pace of research.
To illustrate
that, I just wanted
to show you how fast
publications on Cas9
are exploding.
So if you're a
biologist and you look
at PubMed, which is a
database of publications,
you've probably noticed
something like this.
After a couple of
initial papers, I mean,
this has just exploded.
I actually got these
numbers in 2015.
This is the number of
papers in PubMed per week.
So there' ve been about 1,000
publications in the last three
years.
In the last week,
there were four.
So it's really exploded.
And it's not like these are
all coming from one lab.
I mean, that would be an
extremely prolific lab.
The reason you see so many
publications is it's a tool.
Right?
You can ask whatever question
you're interested in.
If you're a
developmental biologist,
you can ask a
developmental question.
If you're a cancer biologist,
you can ask a cancer question.
It's, I think, very
rapidly becoming less
about the tool and more
about what questions you ask.
And I think that's
really very exciting.
I think in terms of, when
people think about editing
of organisms, therapies,
things like that, that's really
also highlighted by increasing
the number of publications that
just mention the term
"genome editing."
So right around the time
that Cas9 came around,
there were certainly
publications down here,
but they're sort of
hidden by the scale.
Right around the time
Cas9 came around,
and maybe the TALENs, is when
the explosion in the term
"genome editing" came
in the literature.
So everybody's
thinking about it now.
What impact does this have?
Well, today we're
already very quickly
able to identify gene function.
We're able to make very
fast cell and animal models.
And, like I talked about
with the nonmodel organisms,
we have genetics everywhere.
So think of this as
working better and faster.
But what's going to
happen in the future?
So I say "medium term" in sort
of a very vague way, because I
think this is very
soon medium term.
We're going to have
actual therapies
for the hematopoietic system--
the bone-marrow-transplant case
that I saw.
The people pushing
this in the clinic
are a company called
Sangamo, in the Bay Area.
I want to introduce
you to Tim Brown.
He is the so-called
"Berlin patient."
So he had HIV, and he got
a bone-marrow transplant
for leukemia.
And he was lucky enough to
get a transplant from someone
who had a CCR5 mutation.
And it turns out,
totally coincidentally,
if you have a CCR5 mutation
it makes you immune to HIV,
because the HIV virus
can no longer grab on
to the immune cells.
OK?
And so what Sangamo
has been doing
is taking Tim Brown's
mutation and taking
people who have HIV--
take their own bone marrow
and put that mutation into it.
And so this man, right
here, has been cured of HIV
by getting that mutation
with a zinc finger.
I want to stress
it's zinc fingers.
OK?
So we're not seeing Cas9
in the clinic, right now.
It's a matter of time.
But we are doing this, and
I'm almost certain this
is going to happen.
It's letting us also build
better disease models.
And synthetic biology
in general has really
sat up and taken notice
of this sort of thing.
In the long term,
I almost hesitate
to guess what's going to happen.
I mean, this is where we start
to get into science fiction.
And anything I say is
going to be proven wrong.
Certainly people
are already thinking
about in-vivo therapies,
where maybe someone has
muscular dystrophy-- which
is a disease of the muscle--
and you might want to correct
that-- something that's not
in the hematopoietic system.
There are a lot
of problems there.
People have talked
to me about things
like designer organizations--
stuff like that.
We heard about
personalized medicine.
So one thing and I
think fast gene editing
enables is personalized cures.
So, just by way of
background, before I
was recruited to Berkeley,
I was at Genentech.
And when pharma companies are
talking about personalized
medicine, they're usually
thinking on a different scale.
They're thinking about--
you sequence people,
and you put them in bins.
Now, those bins are not,
quote-unquote, "personalized"--
one or two.
Those are 100,000
people, 500,000 people,
a million people.
OK?
It's very powerful.
You're making sure people
get the right medicine.
But if someone has
a unique mutation,
it's very difficult to think
about how to cure that.
And I think when we have very
fast, cheap, and easy gene
editing, that's a
technical possibility.
There's still a lot
of regulatory hurdles.
How do you do a clinical
trial for something
when there's only one patient?
What does an N-of-1
trial even look like?
And these are
outstanding questions
that I think that regulatory
bodies, as well as patients,
need to really weigh in on.
I only have two minutes left.
Since this is a
science symposium,
I was going to put in
leading-edge data-- stuff that
is coming out of my lab.
This is in review right now.
All I wanted to say, since
I only have two minutes,
is that we've figured out
a way to do the editing
part-- the replacement
of sequences--
very, very quickly and easily.
So we can add patient
mutations in really quickly.
We can make mutants
to test mechanism.
We can start tracking
genes very easily.
We can even go backwards
and we can do cures.
And we can do this with
basically the same frequency
that you would
normally do knockout.
So it seems to work
very, very well.
And we think this is going
to be a really important tool
for introducing cures.
I'm going to skip over
the data, unfortunately,
because I sort of waxed
philosophic too long.
We were really asking
how is it that Cas9
works when it grabs onto DNA.
What's really happening
in this question mark?
And also, one thing
I want to stress,
for people in the audience,
is you hear a lot about Cas9.
It's only three years old.
Right?
The most amazing, advanced
lab in the world-- I always
tell this to students-- the
most amazing, advanced person
in the world has only been
working on these problems
for three years.
This is this huge
opportunity for people
to do really amazing
work in this field.
We don't understand,
really, what
happens in this black
box between Cas9 cutting
and editing.
And there's a lot of
good reason to think
that what we have assumed is
not what's really happening.
I'm going to skip over the data.
We found some really fun stuff.
It lets us make really,
really good edits,
so we can have really fantastic
conversion to edited cells.
It works in a variety
of loci, and it also
works in disease states.
This is what happens
when I try to put data
into a more sort of
broad, philosophic talk.
The one thing I want
to leave you with
is, really, how do we
understand this new ability?
Right?
It wasn't so long ago that
next-gen sequencing came around
and we were able to read
genomes very, very quickly.
And now we're very quickly
able to edit genomes.
There are genome-wide libraries
for doing Cas9 cutting.
Like I said, we have
undergraduates and high-school
interns coming in and
doing this sort of stuff.
It's really accessible.
But I do want to point
out that trust in science
is a very fragile thing.
And almost everybody
in the world
has a preconception of
what gene editing is,
because they may have read
a science fiction story
or seen a movie.
Maybe they saw Gattaca.
They think they know
what gene editing is.
And that may or may not be
what gene editing actually,
is in terms of the
technology we have
and the technology
maybe in the future.
And I think that's
really borne out
by some of the
articles that have
been written pretty recently.
So, for better or worse,
I spend a lot of time
talking to the press,
because I work on Cas9.
And invariably,
no matter how much
I try to tell them it's about
disease, that, you know,
it's not about designer babies,
you end up with-- you know,
The Economist had a
designer baby on the cover.
It just happens.
Right?
Because this is what
people want to think about
and they want to talk about.
And I think we do need
to engage this head-on,
as a community of scientists.
But we need to be very
honest and open about it
and talk to people about
what it really means.
I want to end by saying
germ-line editing is
potentially a real
thing to think about.
I think that it's not
real, in terms of no one
has done it yet.
Someone has tried.
They were never going to
implant these zygotes,
but they were able to show
that they could make indels
in human zygotes.
These were not brought to term.
There were some problems
with those edits.
They had a lot of
off-targets-- things like that.
As the result of seeing some
of that stuff, we at the IGI
called a meeting in
Napa with a couple
of people that were initially
involved in the Asilomar
discussions on recombinant DNA.
And after that meeting we
pushed very hard for the IOM
and the NAS to take that on.
Actually, today's
the second, right?
I think tomorrow is
when there's going
to be a-- what happens
when the NAS gets involved
is now there's going to be a
premeeting to plan the meeting.
And so that meeting--
the premeeting
to plan the meeting
is happening tomorrow.
And there's going to be a large
National Academy of Sciences
meeting in December
to talk about what
is human germ-line editing, what
are the guidelines around it.
I think that's very important,
because right now, in the US,
the FDA has said, we will
not sanction any research,
at all, that involves
germ-line editing.
Even if it's not for
reproductive purposes.
Even if, you know, the zygotes
are going to be terminated.
Even if it's going to be for
a purely basic research thing
and we're just going to do the
edit, find out what genes do.
It is completely not allowed.
-Human.
Human.
Sorry.
Yeah.
And so I don't want to say one
way or the other-- you know,
is that good, is that bad.
What I want to say,
though, is right now
it's this complete restriction.
We called for a
temporary moratorium.
We did not mean
to say, you know,
no one ever do it ever again.
I think that's part of
the conversation-- is what
those guidelines look like.
I want to end up by thanking.
These are the people who
really do the work in my lab.
One of my lab's
favorite things is
this giant scissors that we
bought, as you might imagine.
[LAUGH]
[LAUGHTER]
We told them that we were
going to go up to this place
where there's this
giant thing of DNA.
And, like, we had photos
from the lab the next day.
And they were on Amazon
within 10 minutes,
and they had, like, next-day
delivery of the scissors,
they were so excited.
Anyway, we have a website--
innovativegenomics.org.
I'm on Twitter.
I try to be more active on it.
It's hard to keep up, sometimes.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
-Well, that was clearly
a fabulous lead-off.
I would only suggest that
the future isn't the future
anymore, because genome
editing of blood cells that
are taken from
children, in particular,
with hematologic disorders.
Their own cells are corrected
in the laboratories at the Dana
Farber Institute and also at
Children's Hospital Boston
and reimplanted
into those children.
And all of the posttransplant
rejection problems
that I grew up with, when I did
my clinical training, are gone.
So it is not so far off.
I'd also mention that we
haven't yet really mentioned
a lot of the use
of this technology
for fundamental research
in ways that it has
propelled beyond our belief.
You all have heard about induced
pluripotential stem cells--
that we can take a blood sample
or a cell from a urine specimen
and we can, from that,
deconvolute the cell so
that it does not know what was
the tissue it was derived from.
And then we can alter
its genetic information
and grow it back into
a heart cell, which
is really important, because
we have no heart cell lines--
none-- in any species,
including human.
And we can, for the first
time, study these in a dish.
This provides an opportunity
that we simply could not
do without combining both lots
of advanced cell therapies
with the capacity to editing.
So when you hear that
the world is just
beginning to use this
technology, Jacob's 100% right.
OK.
We're going to turn now
to hear a little bit more
about the practical use and
the forward-looking, creative
medical use of editing
at a broader scale.
And Alison Murdoch, from
our colleagues in the United
Kingdom, is going to tell us
about the application of this
in human disease.
I'd like to remind all of you
that our parochial view of what
is right and wrong
is sometimes very
different on the other
side of the big pond.
So we look forward to hearing
all about these comments.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-I'm tempted to say,
gosh, follow that.
First of all, thank you
very much for asking
me to come and speak to you.
It's not only an
honor to come here,
but I would never
refuse an opportunity
to come to your
lovely city of Boston.
So thank you.
What I'm going to talk
about is the translation
of a scientific procedure
into the clinic.
And what's interesting
is that it's actually
almost the present in the
UK, but it's probably still
somewhere in the
future in the US.
And that's why half of what
I'm going to talk about today
is not about the
clinical condition
or the scientific
solutions we have
but actually the
way that, in the UK,
we've gone about the
ethics and the politics
and why it's actually managed
to get us to that situation.
So, first of all,
the clinical problem.
And forgive me for
very complicated slide.
It's actually
deliberately complicated.
Mitochondria, as
we've already heard,
are little organisms within
every single cell of our body
that make the energy.
The number of
mitochondria and the type
of mitochondria in different
organisms, in different cells,
change.
And therefore if a mitochondria
is defective in one
particular tissue
type, it's going
to give a different
sort of disease
than it will be if it's
in a different issue.
Also, the severity
of the condition
will vary considerably,
both depending
on the mutation of
the mitochondria
and the number of abnormal
mitochondria in each cell.
So just about any cell in
the body that requires energy
has the potential to be harmed
by mitochondria disease.
And therefore we
get a whole variety
of different clinical
situations such as this.
Well, as I say, 90% of the
cellular energy within a cell
comes from the mitochondria.
It contains its own genome.
As I said earlier, it's
thought that the mitochondria
originally come
from bacteria that
became incorporated into
single-cell organisms, all
those years ago.
And by providing all
that extra energy,
that allowed all
these single cells
to get together and make
complex cellular structures
that we have now.
There is a debate about how
much the mitochondria talks
to the nucleus.
And I'm not even
going to begin to talk
about the complex
diagram that's there.
The evidence would
suggest, though,
that in clinical
practice there is not
any compatibility problem
between the mitochondria
and the nucleus.
And that's because we
reproduce across ethnic groups
quite easily.
We've also heard, of course,
that the mitochondria
is transmitted down
the maternal line.
The sperm does obviously
have some mitochondria,
because it moves.
It has to have some
energy from somewhere.
But it's thought that
the mitochondria that's
within the sperm is removed at
the time of the fertilization.
The amount of DNA,
obviously, in the nucleus
is huge, compared to the amount
of DNA within mitochondria.
Those who work in
the fertility field--
and when I give this talk
to the fertility audience,
I really, really say the first
message you must go home with
is that mitochondria
transfer is not
a treatment for infertility.
It's nothing to do with IVF.
It's a potential
treatment for people who
carry mitochondrial disease.
But what they've done is looked
at oocytes at different levels
and looked at the copy
numbers of mitochondria
within the oocytes.
And you see huge variations.
But actually there's no evidence
that the number of mitochondria
within an oocyte have any
clinical significance,
in terms of the development
potential of that egg
to make an individual.
So, in clinical practice, we
start to get a little bit more
complicated.
This is an example
from a woman who
carried this particular
mutation of mitochondria.
But she had
different proportions
of abnormal mitochondria
in each cell in her body.
So there was 18%
in her quadriceps
and 7% in leucocytes.
But when they then
look at her oocytes,
we found that the mutation
load varied from anything
from 0% to 45%.
So it's going to be really
difficult to predict,
for the women who carry
mitochondrial disease, what
their chances are that they're
going to have a baby that's
going to have a problem.
Here's an example.
This mum, here-- I should
say "mom," shouldn't I?
I'm in the wrong place.
--mom had 38%
abnormal mitochondria.
She was actually
physically well.
She had no clinical
significant symptoms at all.
She had a daughter who had no
abnormal mitochondria at all
and was almost
perfectly healthy.
But her son had 78%
abnormal mitochondria,
and he died at the age of seven.
So what's her chances?
What are her
options, if she wants
to try and make sure she doesn't
have a child with a problem?
Well, of course, she
can have egg donations.
She can take the whole egg from
some other woman, fertilized
with her husband's
sperm, put back in her.
And that would give her
pretty much guarantee
that she's not going
to have a child
with mitochondrial disease.
But it won't have any of
her nuclear genome, either.
And, for a lot of
these women, this
is just not something that
they would want to consider.
We could do prenatal diagnosis,
we can do amniocentesis,
and we can determine
what carrier
the child is going to have.
But obviously the
only option for then
is the question
about termination.
Because it's so
difficult to identify
what the clinical phenotype
of that child is going to be,
it makes that decision
about whether to terminate
the pregnancy even
more difficult.
We can do PGD, and we do do PGD.
So you can take a biopsy
of an egg and a cell
from an embryo at about three
days after infertilization
and look at the mutation.
But that's not always
very easy, either.
Because you don't get, as you
would do with a nuclear DNA--
you don't get a yes or no.
You get a percentage.
So if you're lucky and you find
that, in that cell that you
take out from the embryo,
there's no mutations at all,
you can probably say that
child's going to be OK.
At less than 30%, there's a
lifetime risk, but it's low.
Once you get higher
levels of that,
you start to get an increasing
chances that that child's going
to be affected.
The problem we have with
PGD is that, once you
start sticking a needle into
an embryo and taken cells out,
you start to
compromise the embryo.
Its ability to go on and
then develop and implant
is going to be disruptive.
So you're then not only going
to look at mutation load you've
got in that embryo,
you've got to look
at the quality of that embryo.
Do you put back a
blastocyst, for instance,
that's a really
perfectly good blastocyst
but maybe have a 20% chance
of carrying a disease,
or one that's not so good but
might only have a 5% but looks
like it's actually going to
be more likely to implant?
Complicated decisions
that need to be made.
But for some people,
there are better options.
And that would be to try and
do mitochondrial transfer.
This is not three years
old-- three months old
or three years old.
This is more like 15 years old.
The Newcastle team, led at
that time by Doug Turnbull,
spoke to the chief medical
officer in the UK at the time
that they were looking
at the regulations,
the potential legislation
around themselves.
And the document
he put forward then
includes a chapter
on the potential
that we saw at that time that
doing mitochondrial transfer
was something that
we would start
doing-- that we thought we might
be able to do in the future.
And I think this was
the important thing
about anticipating in advance
what was going to happen,
to give ourselves time
to get the legislation
through in parallel.
The techniques
we're talking about
was this, which is the diagram
that Janet was speaking
to you about at the beginning.
Basically, you take an
egg that's a donor egg.
You fertilize it.
And then you take out the
male and female pronucleus.
So you end up with an egg
that's got no nucleus in,
but it's got normal
mitochondria.
You basically do the
same from the egg
from the affected
woman, but then you
take out the nuclear genome from
the defected woman, put it back
into the donor egg, and
the resulting embryo
will be a healthy child, as
far as the mitochondria is
concerned.
But it will be genetically
related to mum and dad.
Sounds too easy, doesn't it?
-[LAUGH]
-Of course, in order
to do that, you
have the potential that
you're going to create embryos
and then you're going
to discard them.
So someone said, well, why
don't we do spindle transfers
as an alternative?
That means taking the
genetic material from the egg
before it is fertilized.
Then you only need to create
an embryo with-- basically,
the final embryo that
you're going to put back.
The problem is that, when
you're looking at the spindle,
I don't know if any of
you can see the spindle
in that top, unfertilized egg.
You can see it quite easy
in the fertilized egg
because the male and
female chromosomes
are in that little
package karyotype
that you can see very clearly.
You can use special polarized
light to actually see it.
And you actually
see the spindle.
The spindle's the line
that holds the chromosomes.
But the problem
is you're not only
taking out the chromosomes.
You've got to take out
all the proteins that
go with the spindle, to make
the spindle work properly.
And then, if you're not
careful, you're going to take,
potentially, some abnormal
mitochondria, to as well.
So you've got to be really
careful what you do.
Meiosis II, which is the state
at which you're doing this,
is a really very
highly dynamic state.
And it's very sensitive
to disruption.
So we've really got to
be careful about what
we're doing at this time.
However, the
spindle-transfer technique
has been shown to be successful.
These are the two monkeys that
came from the Oregon group.
Obviously these monkeys
are perfectly healthy,
but they did actually
publish in the paper
that there was quite a
high degree of abnormality
in the batch of embryos
that they actually created.
Although subsequent
to that I think
they have improved
the technique,
and they are getting
better success rates.
So there are two
potential options, there--
this one perhaps
compromised by the fact
that they tried to take
a patent out on it.
And that's a different
issue altogether.
So what are the issues
that we've had to address?
And this is where they've
gone down in parallel.
The scientific work-- basically,
does it work, is it efficient,
is it safe?
That's been led by
Mary Herbert, who's
a senior scientist
on laboratory,
and Louise Hyslop, who's our
clinical embryologist, who
really has the green
fingers to make it work.
And my role has been
more going along
the line of looking at
the regulatory and ethical
[INAUDIBLE].
How could we find to
get it to the point
that it would be
legal to do in the UK?
Because at this time, when
we started, it was not legal.
And how would we take the
population along with us?
How would we make them see
that it was actually perhaps
an ethically
acceptable thing to do?
So, on the science
side-- and, as I say,
this is 15 years' work.
First of all, Doug Turnbull and
his team did work with mice.
They did the pronuclear
transfer techniques,
and they got live
pups, and they showed
that the mitochondria
carryover was sufficiently
low to be acceptable.
We then got permission from
the Human Fertilisation
and Embryology Authority,
who are regulators in the UK,
to do work on abnormally
fertilized human eggs.
When you do IVF, you will
often end up with eggs that are
fertilized but there's only one
[? pronucleus ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? with ?] the three
or more pronuclei.
And in order to show that
these techniques would work,
we would switch over them
over So we ended up with two
and then developed them.
That was the work that
was published in Nature
five years ago.
And, on the back
of that, we then
got permission from the
HFEA to do the techniques
in normal eggs.
So these are eggs
donated by healthy women
in order to do the procedure.
We had to work out what
tests we would need to do,
because not only can we
actually do the technique,
but we've got to show that
it's going to be safe.
So we need to look things
like do the technique
and then look at the karyotype--
look at the epigenetics.
We had a problem
in saying, well,
in order for it
to be safe, you've
got to compare it
with something.
What do you compare it with?
Because there isn't
a normal-type embryo
that's an in-vivo embryo that
you could compare it with.
And the best we
thought we could find
would be the ICSI
embryos that are
created, because
these are embryos
what are already manipulated.
They've already had
needles stuck into them
as part of the IVF process.
So we felt if we could
end up with embryos which,
by everything that we measure,
were going be the same as ICSI,
then we were probably as
good as we were going to get.
Just very briefly, this
is some of the work
that came from the Nature.
And you see, in
figure B, you can
see a one-pronuclear embryo.
In C, you can see three.
Basically, we take
them out, so we end up,
with D, with no
nuclear material.
And then we take
two, put them back,
activate the cell to make
it grow, and then go on.
And we get blastocysts.
Unmanipulate controls were 17%.
And the pronuclear-transfer
ones were 8%.
Those are low, compared
to any IVF program.
But don't forget these are
abnormally fertilized embryos
in the first place.
What we showed, basically,
are proof of principle
that you could
actually do it and you
could get onward development
of embryos from that.
And then, of course, you want
to look at the mean carryover
of the mitochondria.
And the mean was less than 2%.
So we felt we were getting,
in this particular study,
down to levels that would
be clinically acceptable.
Just as a slight sideline,
before I forget to mention it,
less than 2% is the point
at which you would not
expect any abnormal mitochondria
to be passed onto the germ
line of any children
that will be conceived
as a result of treatment.
So you're not any potentially
helping this child,
but you're potentially
helping, if she's
a female, her children, as well.
So where are we, at the moment?
Well, we're getting eggs
donated from healthy volunteers.
We're looking to
develop the techniques.
evaluate the embryos,
we're looking at the
mitochondrial carryover,
and we're looking at
the efficiency of it.
We're also working with
the scientific advisors
of the HFEA, because
they're the ones we're
going to have to
convince when we put
an application in
to the HFEA to say,
now can we do it for treatment?
So we needed to
be absolutely sure
that all the experiments
that they were going
to ask us to do we would have
information about, so we were
not running behind
ourselves, at the same time,
thinking there's
going to someone
that's going to trip us over,
at some point in the future.
So let's move on to
regulation and ethical issues.
These are all the bodies that,
in the UK, have looked at it.
And I'll go through some
of these in more detail.
I've put them into two big
groups, there-- one egg
donation and one to
mitochondrial donation--
because those who were
opposed to what we did
realized very early on that
if we didn't have egg donors
we couldn't do the work.
So we were challenged very
heavily by people who said,
it's not ethical for
you to ask young women
to donate their eggs.
This is different from
any other medical research
where we have
healthy volunteers.
And a lot of very
sensible people
thought that they knew better
than the women themselves
who were coming
to us and saying,
yes, we will help donate, and
trying to stop us doing it.
So that's been a bit of
a hurdle to get over.
And then the question of
the mitochondrial donation,
as well, has been well debated.
I've put in the
social-science literatures
there, because it
had been a field
day for social scientists,
over the past 10 years or so.
I find myself the subject of
PhD theses of social scientists.
So we're feeding a whole
different academic discipline.
Very briefly, though, in terms
of altruistic egg-donation
for research.
These are two documents
that you can go and look at,
if you want more
details about it.
The HFEA did a report in 2006,
which we call the SEED Report.
Now that was the donation
of sperm and eggs
for clinical treatment.
But it was a year later that
they went back and said, well,
if we're going to allow
eggs and sperm to be donated
for treatment, why
shouldn't we actually
do it for research, as well?
That, we thought,
was a good idea.
The bottom line of
their discussions
also included the
question about payment.
And they agreed
that we could pay
up to 750 pounds per donation
to cover their expenses.
The Nuffield
Council on Bioethics
also looked at the question
about egg donation.
They did a wider
study which looked
at the whole question
about participation
in medical research,
organ donation,
the whole question about
medical parts being
used for clinical
practice and for donation.
But they include a chapter
on eggs for research,
as well, because it was
very topical at the time.
And basically they're
saying that they
didn't think there was
going to be a problem
Why should it be regarded
as anything different?
The use of the eggs
might be contentious,
But the actual
process of donation,
if the women wanted to
donate, was no more ethically
challenging than any
other participation
in medical research.
The Nuffield Council also looked
at the mitochondrial transfer.
And this is why I should
declare an interest.
Because I was actually on the
Nuffield Council at this time.
But I didn't have any part to
play in their deliberations.
I actually left
the room whenever
this particular
document was discussed.
It's a very detailed document.
And those of you that are
interested in the ethical issue
should go and read it.
I just picked out four parts,
just to go through in outline.
Initially, I think,
people thought
we were trying to deny that
it was germ-line therapy.
But that was never
the intention.
And we were always very clear,
right from the beginning,
this is germ-line therapy.
There is no point in removing
the mitochondria for a woman
so she can be
healthy but passing
the same risk on to her child.
And, in fact, germ-line therapy,
in this particular case,
is exactly what we want.
Got into some difficulty--
some people suggesting,
well, why don't we then do PGD
and only put back male fetuses,
because the male
fetus is not going
to pass on that mitochondria
to the next line?
Well, hang on-- that's a bit
of sex discrimination, there.
We can't have that.
But there's a nice
debate about that.
There's the whole ethical
issues about doing procedures
that are basically experimenting
on a child that's unborn
and what the rights
of that child
might have to have any
say in what's being done.
One of the issues
that's different here
than the sort of things
become challenging with IVF
and infertility is
it this is a child
that is likely to be born with
a very high risk of having
a serious medical problem.
And what we're doing
with these techniques
is reducing the risk.
It is absolutely true that
this child is not being
given any choice in the matter.
But I think we have to take a
little bit of responsibility
for doing our best
to try and reduce
the chance, as far of possible,
that that child will be OK.
There was a lot of debate about
mitochondrial DNA and identity.
Clearly it doesn't produce
the same identity issues
as the nuclear DNA does.
There was discussion
about whether,
if you have an
abnormality of your DNA
that makes you ill,
then that illness
is part of your identity.
We get slight mixed
messages about that.
Why would we try and cure
anybody, if that were the case?
The state of the mitochondrial
donor-- big debate,
and a very important
debate, because it's
going to depend on what
relationship, then,
the mitochondrial
donor would have
with any child or any family
that might be conceived,
as a result. There's
two arguments.
One what was that you can
say the mitochondrial donor
is the same as an egg donor.
So an egg or a sperm
donor, in order
to have a child, in the UK that
donor has to give their name
and has to potentially allow
the child to contact them
when that child's 18.
That really restricts the
number of donors we get.
Alternatively, you could think
of the mitochondrial donor
as being someone like a
blood donor-- an organ donor.
And there are two different
ways of looking at it.
Fortunately, the
way the regulations
have come out because
of where I wanted
it to be, they've come more down
the line of the blood donor,
not the whole-egg donor.
So our conclusion was
that, on balance, we
believe that these
novel techniques,
if they are adequately
proven to be acceptably
safe and effective
as treatments,
it would be ethical for
families to use them.
And if they wish to
do, and have been
offered an appropriate level
of information and support.
And this particular document
that's came out was really
helpful, when the debate came
in Parliament to say [? we ?]
[? could ?] move ahead with it.
So-- UK legislation.
The act relating to what we
can do with human embryos,
preimplantation, was in 1990.
It's very good legislation,
because it gives us a good
framework that says what
we can and we cannot do.
And as long as we abide
by that legislation,
we're going to be OK.
I would have to say that the
way that it's implemented
by the authority that regulates
is perhaps a little bit more
robust than will be helpful.
They needed to come
back to it later on,
because the original
act of Parliament
does allow us to do some
research on embryos,
but it was restricted.
So we could do
research to understand
the cause of infertility.
We could do research on
embryos to understand
the cause of miscarriage.
But once you start getting
into potential research
to treat serious diseases
like mitochondria,
it wasn't covered by the act.
So they came and
revised it in 2001,
so that then it was possible
to research on embryos
for the purpose of
understanding the causes
and developing treatments
for serious diseases.
I've put in the
cloning act, there.
There was a slight miswording
in the original act that
meant potentially that
reproductive cloning could
legal in the UK.
They very quickly stopped
that, as soon as they
realized that was a problem.
We are not cloning.
The act was revised
in 2008, because that
was at the point at
which we were-- it was
a routine review of the act.
But we were saying
then, we're not that
far away from being
able to come to you
and say this is actually
someone we'd like to do.
So the important thing
in the act in 2008
was they put a clause in
that said we would not
need to go back to
primary legislation
in order to allow this to
become legal in the UK.
It was still illegal,
under the act,
but they said that we could go
back to the secretary of state
and ask permission.
And that would allow
us to get it through.
But it would need to go back
to debate in Parliament.
So the regulations
that were put together
that will make this
something that we
can do-- these techniques
for nuclear transfer
an spindle transfer-- make them
legally acceptable techniques
were put to Parliament.
They were debated and voted
in the House of Commons
in February this year.
Massive vote in favor.
And then, in the House of Lords,
later in February, again, 208
for and 48 against.
It was pretty overwhelming.
I was in the debate for
the House of Lords one.
I'd never seen so many
members of the House of Lords,
because usually they
sleep in the back benches.
But it was very full.
But even the bishops who
were there were abstaining--
were saying, we're understanding
humanity-- what it was
and what we were trying to do.
I think the big
advantage in the UK
this it's not a party
political issue.
This was a free vote.
It was based on
consciences alone,
and that was very helpful.
Issues related to reproduction
legislation in the UK
has never been a
party political issue.
So where we are now--
these procedures
were passed by
Parliament in February.
They will become the law
at the end of October.
That means at that
point we can apply
to be the HFEA for a license.
At that point, the
scientific data
will be reviewed by the HFEA.
And if they say that
we have provided
the evidence as
necessary, we hope
we'll get a license to do it.
So we could be in
a position to be
able to offer this in treatment
within the next few months.
I'm going to give you just a
little bit about the science
where they are.
Because, obviously, the
science is developing.
We're getting 92% oocytes
surviving the pronuclear
transfer procedure.
And the blastocycte development
right now has gone up to 54%.
Louise is really
green-fingerprinting
these techniques.
Obviously the data
that's really important
is looking at the carryover,
looking at the chromosomes,
looking at stem cells
that have been derived
and what the deal is.
I'm not going to
give you this now,
because it's too
politically sensitive,
and it's not
appropriate to give you
that sort of scientific
data before it's actually
formally gone to peer review.
Mary Herbert, who's the
scientist that leads this,
is a very good scientist.
She's very careful, and
she's very cautious.
Her team is small,
but it's really good.
The way that the
science has developed
in this particular
area of procedures
has to be slightly different.
It's not any good
to be the "I want
to be the first in Nature
for the publication"
and then get it wrong
and make a mistake.
What we need to do is
to be absolutely sure
that, when we get
it published, it's
as good as it's going
to be, it's robust,
and that will give us
the safety of issues
that we need to have
to make it work.
So these are the
scientists that were here.
Now, obviously, there
have been an awful lot
of other people
who've been involved,
talking about the ethics,
the lobbying, the politics.
But I'm going to pick out just
one group on my final slide,
just to say.
The Lily Foundation
was an organization
that was set up
by Lily's parents
to support research and develop
treatments to help prevent
mitochondrial disease.
Lily died at the age
of eight months old
from mitochondrial disease.
It was Lily's parents, and
like her who went to the press.
They went on the radio,
they went to the newspapers,
and told their stories.
They took their babies
into the television studios
and showed them to
people and said,
my baby's going to die
in a few months' time.
And really that
was the thing that
was most powerful in getting
it to the stage in the UK
that it is now.
I think Lily won, in the end.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Clearly, they are
leading new frontiers
and are grappling with issues
that we'll have an opportunity
to learn from, as
this technology--
which, to the best
of my knowledge,
exists nowhere at
the development stage
that it is in
Newcastle-upon-Tyne--
we'll have the opportunity
to learn from them,
as we go forward.
The hour's late.
I want to move on
to our last speaker.
If we can find DNA, sequence
DNA, and change DNA,
is that enough?
And our last speaker
will tell us No,
because he's a
synthetic biologist,
and he's going to make new DNA.
If he can find his pointer.
[LAUGH] There we go.
Sorry.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
-Yeah.
So, hi.
So my name's Floyd Romesberg.
It's a real pleasure
to come to tell you
about some of the
research in my group
at the Scripps
Research Institute.
So fundamentally what
I'm interested in
and what my group works
on are different aspects
of thinking about
evolution and applying it.
And it's all from a very
much chemist's perspective.
I'm a chemist by training.
And so what I'm so what the
project's largely focused on
are trying to develop--
use concepts from evolution
to develop novel approaches
to antibiotics discovery,
biophysical characterization,
to understand
the process of evolution.
And what I'm going to
talk to you about today
is an attempt to expand
the genetic alphabet--
to augment the potential of
what evolution can do so.
So the project, especially
in its early days,
was focused very much on
expanding the genetic alphabet.
So there it is.
That's the genetic
alphabet of E. coli.
If you can't see it, let
me blow it up for you.
So I gave this talk in
China, about a year ago.
And someone came up to
me afterwards and said,
you know, you have
a lot of nerve,
showing the Japanese
flag in China.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway.
So the genetic alphabet
in all organisms-- and I
could've told you-- I
mean, this is E. coli,
but it looks pretty
much the same.
It's just long strings
of Gs, Cs, As, and Ts.
And Gs pair with C,
and As pair with T.
And that's the mechanism
of replication and storage
and retrieval of
genetic information.
And so, if one were
interested in expanding that,
to create an
organism that stored
more information-- eventually
could retrieve more
information-- such
a semisynthetic cell
might look something like this.
There's a variety
of things you'd
have to be concerned about.
You'd have to have your
unnatural nucleotide.
So you'd have to have a
third pair of nucleotides.
So G, C, A, and T
are all nucleotides.
You'd have to have nucleotide
X and nucleotide Y.
And X and Y would have
to pair with each other.
So, for example, if you
had Y in a piece of DNA
during DNA
replication, you'd have
to have the correct
triphosphate that's
the activated form
of the nucleoside
that the polymerase needs.
You'd have to have that
polymerase faithfully
and with high
efficiency recognize
the unnatural nucleotide
in the template
and put in its cognate
pair in the growing strand,
during replication.
And then, of course, you'd
have to have an RNA polymerase.
You'd have to have the requisite
triphosphates available
within the cell.
You'd have to have an
RNA polymerase, then,
that recognizes
templates containing
DNA genes-- for
example, containing
the unnatural nucleotide--
to produce RNA strands that
contain the unnatural nucleotide
which would go out and find
the ribosome and
maybe direct tRNA--
the ribosomes-- to synthesize
proteins containing
unnatural amino acids.
So I don't have a lot of
time to tell you about what
our interest and why we're
so interested in eventually
getting to the state
of producing proteins
with unnatural amino acids.
But suffice it to say that
protein therapeutics are
a big deal, despite
having really
limited chemical functionality
available within them.
And if one could expand the
scope of what proteins could
be made, maybe even
in evolvable context,
one could imagine
developing therapeutics that
really revolutionize medicine.
So at this point I do want to
acknowledge the seminal work
of a couple people.
Peter Schultz, who has worked
with recoding an amber codon.
So, of the 64
possible codons that
are available in natural
DNA, three of them
are reserved as stop signals.
And Pete was clever
enough to figure out
how to take one of those
and have it recognized
by an unnatural-- a tRNA from
a different organism that
was charged by an enzyme
that charges tRNAs
with an unnatural amino acid.
And he a couple of those that
work really want in E. coli.
And partly I'm acknowledging
him because we plan fully
on stealing those tRNAs.
And, instead of recoding
for them with stop codons,
the idea is to generate
with unnatural nucleotides,
essentially, an infinite
number of new codons
that you could use to encode
for unnatural amino acids.
And the second person
I want to mention
is Steve Benner, who was
the first to popularize
the idea of developing
unnatural nucleotides.
And the way Steve
did it was he said,
look-- G-C and A-T sort of
pair in a complementary way,
based on something called
"hydrogen bonding."
So you have a hydrogen donor
here, and an acceptor here,
and that's sticky.
That's water-like.
And he worked for years.
And he's made a lot
of progress, lately.
But one of the
problems that he had
was that those hydrogen-bonding
patterns could scramble.
And because natural G, C, A,
and T recognize each other
based on similar sorts of
hydrogen-bonding patterns,
it was a real fidelity problem.
So his unnatural
nucleotides would
mis-pair with the natural ones.
So the approach that
we took-- I want
to give you a couple examples.
Now there's way more
information here than I want
you to absorb in any detail.
So, first of all,
what I'm showing here
is the nucleobase
of the nucleotides.
So this is the part that
pairs with each other.
The rest of the nucleotide
has a little sugar, down here,
and maybe a phosphate.
And I'm ignoring
those, for simplicity.
The synthetic
chemists in my lab who
slave away for
years, making these,
love me reducing
them to this little--
So one thing I want
to mention about this
is that we did not
take Steve's approach.
We took up-- these are
all hydrophobic, oily,
greasy-looking.
So everyone knows that
water and oil don't mix.
So that's called the
"hydrophobic effect."
Partly that's the
hydrophobic effect.
Water and oil
exclude each other.
Water likes to be with water,
and oil likes to be with oil.
So we thought, if we make
hydrophobic nucleobases,
maybe they'll pair
with each other
and avoid the more
water-like nucleobases.
And maybe we can start with
greater orthogonality-- greater
ability to not mis-pair with
the natural nucleotides.
So that's one thing about these.
These are all hydrophobic.
They're also large,
because we thought,
heck-- you know, we're taking
the hydrogen bonds out.
What else is going to
stabilize the DNA, if we've
taken the hydrogen ones out?
So we need large
surface area to pair
within a strand of that
double-strand, duplex DNA,
to make it stable.
So that's one thing-- they're
all large and hydrophobic--
that I want to point out.
And the second thing
about the approach we took
is that we didn't take
the traditional sort
of biorganic chemists' approach,
where we make something,
design it very carefully,
maybe, make it, and then spend
a year studying it.
We took a
medicinal-chemistry approach,
where we made lots of
analogs, we analyzed them
with assays that were
very fast, and then
we could evaluate
changes that we made
and build structure activity
relationships-- SARs-- just
like medicinal chemists do.
I'm a huge fan of
medicinal chemists.
And, in that way, optimize
the unnatural base pair.
So the sorts of assays
is not real important.
But we measure the
temperature at which
the duplex falls apart.
That gives you a
measure of stability.
So we put the different
unnatural pairs
within the duplex and
measured stability.
And then the real key
SAR came out of kinetics.
We take a DNA primer-- a
template that has the unnatural
nucleotide ready to direct the
incorporation of its correct
triphosphate, as I mentioned--
and then we add a DNA
polymerase and measure how
quickly and efficiently it can
do that, relative to
potential mis-pairs..
Now there's two steps.
There's an incorporation step.
That's the step where
you actually pull
the unnatural nucleobase
out of solution-- unnatural
nucelotide-- and
covalently attach it
to this primer terminus.
But now the primer
terminus is unnatural.
So the next step of maybe
adding the next correct, natural
nucleotide is different.
So we call that the
"extension" step.
So we evaluate both
of them independently.
The incorporation step
wound up-- in retrospect,
we wound up sort of
referring to this first group
of unnatural
nucleobases' nucleotides
as our first-generation analogs.
And the SAR that
really came out of that
was that those analogs--
we could optimize them
for that incorporation
step to be very efficient.
What became the real challenge
was optimizing this extension
step.
That became the
biggest challenge.
So we solved a structure
of one of the better
of the first-generation
analogs, and that was just
this propinal isocarbostyril.
It's kind of a joke, in
my lab, how we name these.
Because we tried to
be very systematic,
at first, but we've
synthesized about 250.
And you just run out of names.
So we solved the structure
of DNA containing this.
And we solved it with Dave
Wemmer at Berkeley and Pete
Schultz at Scripps.
And here it is.
So here's a piece of duplex DNA.
Here's our little pair,
stuck in the middle.
And you see it doesn't look
like a Watson-Crick pair.
So all these other
pairs-- these G-C pairs--
these famous rungs of the
ladder-- didn't look like that.
It looks like this.
They cross-strand
intercalate, because they're
big and hydrophobic
and greasy, and they're
grabbing onto each other.
And maybe that
doesn't surprise you,
because we didn't design
these to pair with each other.
This just came out of the SAR.
But in our mind's
eye, we thought
that this explained that
SAR that I just described.
So if you imagine this same
modality of interaction
is occurring during replication
in a polymerase-active site--
let's say this is
a template, this
is a growing primer strand.
As you add this
unnatural nucleotide,
it's going to reach out and
intercalate into its-- reach
into its opposite strand.
And most of the distortion that
comes with that pinching down,
for this to happen, is going
to be absorbed by the primer
terminus, because it's less
locked down by the polymerase.
It's more free to move.
So that's why it synthesized
well, because it's getting out
of water.
It doesn't like being in water.
It's hydrophobic.
It's getting to this beautiful
hydrophobic environment
that it loves, but now it has
a distorted primer terminus,
and it can't go on.
So we thought that
explained the data.
So, in what became known as our
"second-generation analogs,"
we made smaller analogs.
And we said, look-- the
incorporation step was
so subject to
optimization, maybe
we can make smaller analogs that
are less prone to intercalate
and optimize the incorporation
step anyway, and then
be in a better position to
optimize extension, as well.
This kind of worked.
And I don't have a lot of
time to explain this to you,
because there's a subtlety.
But there was a real
contradiction in the SAR.
And that was, it had to do with
the nature of the substituent
that I've shown here.
So chemists would call
this the "ortho position"
to the glycosidic bond.
The "glycosidic bond" is just
a name for the sugar bond.
So this is the sugar bond.
And so it's this position
I've noted, there.
In order for the insertion
step to be efficient,
whenever the nucleobase--
the unnatural nucleotide
is in the template or is
the incoming triphosphate,
you want that substituent
to be hydrophobic-- greasy.
But when it comes to the next
step, the extension step,
you still want it
to be hydrophobic
when it's in the
template, but when
it's in the primer terminus
you need it to be hydrophilic.
You need it to accept an H bond.
And for those
polymerase aficionados
in the audience-- I know
there are a couple of you--
it's because the polymerase
is donating an H bond.
It needs to interact in
an H-bonding-like way
with that primer terminus.
So it's not an
H-bond interaction
between the nucleobases,
it's an H bond
between the growing primer
terminus and the polymerase.
So we were kind of stuck,
because that's a contradiction.
How do you make an analog
that's both hydrophobic and
hydrophilic simultaneously?
So we ran a couple of
independent screens
where we screened through
over almost 2,000 candidate
unnatural base pairs.
They were independent screens.
And the only important point
is they both identified
the very same pair-- a
first-generation analog,
and a second-generation analog.
This was the second of a series
of methyl methoxy derivatives,
and this was this 5-methyl
sulfur isocarbostyril.
And notice the nature
of these substituents.
Sulfur is able to accept
a hydrogen bond but not
as good as the oxygen.
But it's still able to.
But it's much more
polarizable and hydrophobic.
So it's a compromise.
And O methyl is
just a bond rotation
away from presenting
a hydrophobic surface
versus an H-bonding surface.
So, at least in
our mind's eye, we
envisioned that was how that
SAR conflict was resolved.
But this very much, very
quickly reinvigorated
our design effort.
And we optimized this pair
by filling in this ring,
here, resulting in what we
called this naphthyl methoxy
or NAM 5,6 pair.
And a lot of what I'm going to
tell you about in this last 13
minutes is work with this pair.
Very recently, we've discovered
this analog of TPT5,6 called
"TPT3," which replicates
better than this pair.
In the early days, we
did a lot of kinetics.
This pair replicates too well to
measure by kinetics-- too fast.
So we use a sequencing method.
So we submit the DNA to
the sequencing facility,
using just standard
Sanger sequencing,
where you don't have the
unnatural triphosphates
present.
You see an abrupt termination at
the spot of the unnatural base
pair.
And you can ratio the amplitudes
and get calibration curves
to determine fidelities.
We've done PCR amplifications.
These are 150 more
pieces of DNA.
And I'm only showing you
the local sequence context
so that we can replicate
in a whole variety
of different sequence
contexts, including
sequence contexts where
the unnatural base
pairs are next to each other.
Now, really quick, I shouldn't
take the time to tell you this,
but I love this story.
This is maybe one my
favorite parts of the story.
We solved the
structure of NAM5,6.
And, lo and behold, it
was intercalated again.
It was a real light-bulb
experience in my life.
They're never going to do this.
There's nothing to be
had-- there's nothing
to be gotten from doing this.
There's no H bonds there.
They're going to do
whatever they can do,
and that's intercalate.
Now, if you go into a medicinal
chemist, and you said,
look, we've got this molecule
with this great activity.
It's a great antibiotic.
And the medicinal chemist
will tell you, well,
what's the target?
And you'll say,
well, I don't know.
Who cares?
It's got this great activity.
You won't get any interest,
because medicinal chemists have
been burned too many
times, chasing ghosts--
chasing artifacts.
So we wanted to know, is this
a harbinger of a problem?
Is there something
going on, here?
Because DNA polymerases don't
recognize things like this.
So how is it that--
I just told you
that it's really
well replicated.
How is that?
This makes no sense.
So let me tell you
what I mean by that.
Here's a G-C base pair.
G paired with C. Doesn't
matter whether it's in a duplex
or whether it's at a
polymerase-active site, where
you're pairing a triphosphate
against a template
during synthesis.
It just looks the same.
A G-C looks the
same as a C-G. It
looks the same as a T-A and an
A-T. They all look the same.
The famous Watson-Crick
base-structure.
There it is.
That's not what ours look like.
Ours are this weird
intercalation.
Ours look more like
an A-A mis-pair.
And how is it that
the polymerases
are recognizing them?
So this is how polymerases work.
Polymerases look
like a right hand.
The template lies down like
this-- in the palm domain.
And when the correct
triphosphate binds,
it induces a large
conformational change
of the fingers domain, down
over the palm and thumb domains.
That forms a tight
complex that's
supposed to rigorously select
for a Watson-Crick base-pair
structure.
So we had two questions.
Number one, does formation of
our unnatural base pair cause
that same conformational change?
Number two, if it does,
what is that closed complex
recognizing?
Because our pair
doesn't look anything
like a Watson-Crick pair.
It looks like a mis-pair the
polymerases were supposed
to have evolved to avoid.
So we collaborated with a good
friend of mine, Andy Marx,
at the University
Konstanz, who solved
a bunch of crystal structures.
I'm willing to show a couple
of the key ones, here.
This is the polymerase,
bound to the primer template.
Here's the only part of the
polymerase I'm showing you.
There are two helices at the
base of that fingers domain
that I mentioned.
And here's our
unnatural nucleotide,
flipped out of the
developing duplex.
Not a big surprise.
Most of the natural
nucleobases do the same thing.
There's a little hydrophobic
pocket right there.
When you add the cognate
unnatural triphosphate,
it flips back in.
And you get a large
conformational change
of that fingers domain.
And, to show you that
conformational change,
here's an overlay of
those two structures.
And you can see the
conformational change,
right there.
To convince you it's
exactly the same
as the conformational change
induced by a natural base pair,
here's an overlay of those
complexes synthesizing
our unnatural base pair
with that synthesizing
a G-C. They're absolutely
superimposable,
at the secondary structure-- the
protein-structure level-- even
at the side-chain level,
and even at the bound water
and magnesium level.
So it really induces the very
same conformational change
in the DNA polymerase.
So now, what about
the second question?
What's that closed
complex recognizing?
And if your eyes are
good, you can already see.
But if your eyes are like
mine, let me help you.
This was a good day in my lab.
The unnatural base
pair's not replicated
by some weird mechanism.
It's replicated by a subtle
variation of the same mechanism
that a natural
pair's replicated by.
A natural pair is replicated by
what's called an "induced fit
mechanism," where
its formation drives
a large conformational
change in the polymerase.
I already mentioned that.
The unnatural base
pair is replicated
by a mutual induced
fit mechanism, where
its formation drives that
large conformational change
on the polymerase, but
that conformational change
on the polymerase drives
a conformational change
of the base pair,
to produce the pair
that it needs for recognition.
And I think the
ability to do this
is exactly what we spent
12 years optimizing on
in that med-chem-like campaign.
I don't think-- if we would have
chosen any other force, other
than hydrophobicity,
I don't think
we would have had this
strength and flexibility
to be able to do this.
Because the hydrophobic
force is strong,
but it's not very directional.
So has the ability to respond to
the environment that it needs.
So, having shown you
that replicates well,
and actually believing that
we understood why-- we're not
getting faked out, we're
not chasing a ghost--
we sort of return to
our idea of trying
to develop a semisynthetic
organism-- trying
to implement the unnatural
base pair in a living cell.
So the first problem that
just jumps out at you
is, how do you get the
triphosphates available?
So anyone who thinks
about nucleotide chemistry
knows there's a couple
things that you could try.
There are several drugs
based on free nucleosides
defusing in through membranes
and then being metabolized up
to this triphosphate
level by enzymes that
are called "salvage" enzymes.
It's one of the ways
cells make triphosphates.
Bacteria do this
very sporadically.
They don't actually
rely on it very much.
And very little was
known about penetration
across the membrane.
Suffice it to say, despite
immense amount of work--
about a year of work-- that
did not work, in my lab.
We could not get that to work.
So there's another
method that I'm not
going to tell you much about.
But you could imagine
protecting the-- I mean,
the reason the triphosphates
won't get in-- they'll
get into through
the outer membrane--
this is a gram-negative--
this is an E. coli
cell-- through channels
called "porins."
They're just these
water channels.
And this hydrophilic is
charged, so it'll diffuse in.
But then it won't be able to
get across this inner membrane--
Which, in this example, is blue.
You might have not known that.
The cytoplasmic membrane
of a gram-negative is blue.
And so the charge prevents that.
So maybe if you put on these
ester-blocking groups that
oblate the charge, it'd
help them diffuse in.
And then, once in,
maybe E. coli will
have these nonspecific esterases
that-- just chop them off,
and you're ready to go.
Doesn't work.
We made 18 analogs like that.
And none of them would work.
So we were really stuck,
not knowing what to do.
This is where I
real-- so I just gave
a talk to the graduate students
at Scripps, at a retreat.
And the whole theme
of my talk was
to think differently, in a
really interdisciplinary way.
And this was the example I used.
It turns out that
there are a variety
of genomes that have this
really interesting property.
And the property is, they
autonomously replicate.
So they have to
have triphosphates,
and-- but they don't
encode the machinery
of triphosphate synthesis.
And these genomes are some
obligate intracellular
bacteria-- some
chlamydial species--
and some plastids in
eukaryotes-- like algae.
So, like mitochondria
and chloroplasts.
What they do is-- I mean,
they live their whole life
inside other cells, bathing in
the nutrients of those cells.
So what they do is
they scavenge instead--
they've just found
it easier to do that.
Over evolutionary time,
they've optimized that.
So what these
organisms do is they
don't make the machinery
of triphosphate synthesis.
What they do is they
make dedicated nucleoside
triphosphate transporters
that assemble in the membrane
and transport the triphosphates,
intact, as triphosphates,
into the cell.
We wrote all across the world
to about 18 different groups.
And a few of them were
willing to send us their DNA.
And so we cloned them
into our E. coli strain
and asked if they would work.
And they did, and we narrowed
it down to three or four.
So this is the strategy.
Because we found
that the idea would
be to get a transporter
here, the triphosphates
would diffuse in
through those porins
and then get into the cytoplasm
through this transporter.
And this particular transporter,
from a chlamydial species-- oh,
I forgot to add a title.
At least you know I got
this talk ready specifically
for you guys.
The transporter that we call
"PTNTT2"-- here's its activity.
So it's importing A.
So what we're using
is a radio-labeled
A triphosphate.
So this is the triphosphate.
This is the diphosphate,
meaning it's
lost one of its phosphates.
This is the monophosphate,
meaning it's lost two of them.
And the product of removing
all three phosphates
of the free nucleoside,
you just can't see,
because the radio label's gone.
But what we were
extremely excited to see
was that it also
imported in the cytoplasm
the triphosphates
of our analogs.
And they decompose,
just like the ATP does.
There's the triphosphate,
there's the di-,
there's the mono-.
Now we can see the
free nucleosides,
because these are HPLC assays,
and we're not relying on radio
labelling.
So you can say, OK, there's a
lot of decomposition, there.
And there is.
And we're working
on solving that.
We're tracking down what the
offending phosphatases are,
and we think we've
finally found it.
And we'll delete them.
But what we noticed, about
a year ago or so-- a year
and a half ago, god
knows-- two years,
or something-- when we
were doing this work
was that, even though these
concentrations were less
than these, these were
30 and 50 micromolar.
That's an order of
magnitude above the km
for the polymerase, suggesting
that these concentrations
should be sufficient.
There should be enough
triphosphate in the cell
to work.
And these are
steady state levels.
These are
concentrations that are
the balance between the
importer pumping them in
and the phosphatases
chewing them up.
So we construct a
couple plasmid packs.
It's the accessory
plasmids, where
we plan on putting all the
accessories that we need
for a semisynthetic organism.
Right now, that's
just the transporter.
And then what we call
"pINF," for information
plasmid.And it's just
pUC-- just pUC19.
The one difference
between pINF and pUC19
is we replaced an
A-T pair with an X-Y.
Now the X-Y was TPT3 dNAM.
Remember this?
This I told you replicated a
little bit better than this.
So when we constructed
this plasmid synthetically,
at our bench, we incorporated
this unnatural base pair.
The experiment that
we're going to do
is with this
unnatural base pair.
And I'll tell you why
we did that a second.
So the experiment is, transform
E. coli with this plasmid
and induce
transporter production
so they're competent to
take up the triphosphates.
Then add the triphosphates.
So transform and induce the
production of the transporter.
Then add the requisite
unnatural triphosphates.
And then add the unnatural
plasmid containing
the unnatural base pair.
And then recover that
plasmid as a function of time
and characterize it.
So there's a couple
control experiments
that we wanted to do.
We wanted to transform
with just pUC19,
so it doesn't have the unnatural
base pair in the template.
So if we're mis-inserting
the triphosphate,
somehow, that's a
control against that.
Or don't induce the
transporter, or don't add
the unnatural triphosphates.
So we recovered the
unnatural plasmid.
We PCR-amplified the region
around the unnatural base pair.
And when we PCR-amplified it,
we incorporated a biotin tag
on one of the
unnatural nucleotides.
And then we looked at a
streptavidin gel shift.
So any place that retained
the unnatural base pair
would then add this tag to it.
And this tag resulted
in a gel shift.
So in the controls where you
don't have the unnatural base
pair in the template, you
never get a gel shift.
When you have the unnatural
base pair in the template
but you don't add the
requisite triphosphates,
you get no shift.
When you have the unnatural
base pair in the template,
and you induce the
triphosphate, but you
don't provide for their
uptake, you don't get a shift.
Only when you have the unnatural
base pair in the template,
provide the triphosphates,
and provide for their uptake
do you get the shift.
The same trick that I
showed you for sequencing,
earlier, I don't know
if you can see this,
but here's just standard
sequencing chromatograms.
Suffice it to say
they look normal.
And then only in the
experiment will you
get the abrupt termination at
the site of the unnatural base
pair.
So we were pretty excited.
We submitted this as a paper.
Two of the three
reviewers agreed with us.
One of the reviewers
didn't like two things.
The reviewer didn't
like this step,
and the reviewer
didn't like this step.
He didn't like the fact that
we were manipulating the DNA
after we got it out of a cell.
So we collaborated
with NEB, which
was a great collaboration.
They have this
beautiful assay where
they take an entire plasmid.
So we'd just recover the
plasmid-- send it to NEB.
They chop it up into
nucleosides and then analyze it
by something called "LC-MS/MS."
It's something that just
separates the nucleotides out
and then uses something called
"mass spectrometry" to identify
them.
Here is the total C
content of the plasmid,
the total G content of the
plasmid, the total A content
of the plasmid.
D doesn't fly well.
It doesn't behave
well in their assay.
And so it was expected
to have a small signal.
But way out here,
right where we knew
it would come, based on
its LC properties, is 5,6.
And it's present
at one per genome.
Now remember, the synthetic
plasmid that we made
was with this.
Was with TPT3.
The only spot that
5,6 was provided
was as a triphosphate
to the media.
There was no detection of TPT3.
It was only 5,6.
So this is ambiguous
demonstration
of replication of the unnatural
base pair inside the cell.
Here is E. coli.
Every organism since
the last common ancestor
of all life on earth has had
two base pairs and four letters.
These growing cells
have six and three.
Very briefly, in the
remaining eight seconds--
negative 8 seconds-- we're
continuing to look at analogs.
We have a whole family of
replicable unnatural base
pairs.
Before, we had this transporter
encoded on a plasmid.
We've now integrated
it into the chromosome.
And, because found
out that it induced
a little bit of toxicity
when we induced it,
and that's why we had to
put on a high copy plasmid,
so we didn't want any
selection pressure to lose it.
We found all that toxicity
came from the N terminus.
I mean, this is a
eukaryotic protein,
so it had signals to guide it
through eukaryotic-specific
parts of the cell that aren't
doing anything, in E. coli.
You delete them, and the
cells are no longer sick.
You can now put it behind
a constituent of promoter,
so they're producing the
transporter all the time.
They're always competent to take
up our natural triphosphates,
and they grow with
wild type rates.
So we've continued to move
on to the next step, now.
And we're looking
at transcription.
And this is all
relatively preliminary,
but let me just finish
by saying we created
another plasmid or this
time put the unnatural base
pair in the gene.
And this time we had to import
the ribo- and the deoxy- ribo
variants of the unnatural
nucleotides, induce T7 RNA
polymerase.
So I didn't tell you,
but, during all that SAR,
part of that
optimization effort,
we also included recognition
by T7 RNA polymerase.
So we wanted to make sure
that we had a base pair that
was also transcribeable into
RNA so that it would produce
the RNA and then analyze it.
And so we isolated the RNA,
reverse-transcribing the PCR
amplifier.
So let me emphasize what
the unnatural base pair has
to do to be detected here.
The unnatural triphosphides
have to get in.
It has to be stably
replicated within the plasmid.
It has to be transcribed by
T7 DNA polymerase into RNA.
It then has to survive
notoriously error-prone
reverse transcription back into
DNA and then PCR amplification.
And there it is.
And we've done it now, in
about three different genes
and a tRNA.
And, with that, it remains
only to thank my group, which
my current group is right here.
And, of course, the New
England Biolabs group
for that collaboration
was absolutely essential.
And I mentioned
these collaborations
for structural work and
these groups for funding.
So, um, yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Very, very, very cool
science, from all three
of our fabulous speakers.
The hour's late, but I think
we have time for questions,
if people want to come
forward, up to the microphone,
and please tell us
who you are, as you
begin to ask your question.
Please.
-My name is Marcy Wells.
And I have a question
about donor eggs.
As I was watching your
presentations, instead
of getting donor
eggs, can you just
repair the mother's
eggs by taking out
the damaged mitochondria?
-There is a suggestion that
there might be potentially
a scientific way to do that.
It's theory.
It's not proven.
The problem we have--
in the UK, anyway--
is that we would not
be allowed to do it
because that would actually
probably be altering a genome.
While it might be considered
legal, it's altering a genome.
And we're not
allowed to do that.
We're allowed to replace
the mitochondria.
We're not allowed
to alter any genome.
-Sir.
-Irwin Shapiro,
astrophysicist at Harvard.
I have a question for Floyd.
Sort of a generic question.
This is very fascinating
work, making more pairs
from the conventional two pairs.
-Yeah, everyone always told
me I should grow-- never mind.
[LAUGHTER]
-Sorry?
-I was going to make
a joke, but then I
pulled appropriately
back at the last second.
-Do you have any speculations
as to why nature zeroed
in on these two pairs-- A-T and
C-G-- as opposed to, say, three
pairs or two other
pairs or whatever?
-So I think it's
really difficult
to ask those kind of
evolutionary questions.
I think they're fascinating, but
they're difficult to disprove.
So it's tough science.
Let me mention a couple things.
-Speculations.
-Speculations-- sure.
And I'm happy to speculate.
But let me mention something
bout our unnatural base pair.
We need the natural
environment provided by C-G
and A-T. We could
never make long
stretches-- we could replicate
long stretches of just X and Y.
Of course, we don't need to.
All we want to do
is evolve proteins
with multiple
unnatural amino acids,
and you would never
need stretches.
I mean, if you only could
incorporate one base pair,
there's more codons
than we could ever use.
I think that, you know, that's
a question that a lot of people
have asked.
Watson very famously called
it a "frozen accident."
I tend to sort of think that
that's probably right, in that,
for whatever reason, it
happened across G-C and A-T--
probably because they
were available, somehow,
in whatever the environment
was at the time.
And they worked good enough.
So, no more selection pressure.
I think all that my work does
is suggest that maybe they
could've done more if
they had wanted to.
-[LAUGH]
-I'll add a question to that.
Given that we can
only sequence DNA
with the way we can
sequence it, how do we know?
-I actually get that
question sometimes.
-[LAUGH] You just did.
[LAUGHTER]
-Good question.
I mean, I think
it's very unlikely
that there's anything as
radically different as NAM
and 5,6.
But-- sure.
-[INAUDIBLE] we know.
-Sure.
-Sir.
-Hi.
I'm Ryan Cross, from the Boston
University Science Journalism
program.
This is a question for Dr. Corn.
Could you speak a little bit
about the non-GMO gene editing
trend that's going on
in biotech right now?
Specifically with
editing plant genomes.
Scientists seem to
have a lot of buzz
about using CRISPR Cas to
navigate around current GMO
regulations.
-Oh.
I mean, I think what
you're referring
to is the current definition
of GMO is that there's
a selection marker in there.
And one of the
possibilities of Cas9
is that you could do the editing
without introducing a selection
marker.
And therefore it would
not be technically GMO.
Out of the companies
that I've talked
to that are serious
players in this game,
they think a lot about how would
their product be perceived.
I don't know if they've
fully learned their lesson,
but they've learned that
people pay attention
to that sort of stuff.
So I have not heard
anyone, so far,
say we want to try
to slide something
under the radar with this.
And I've even heard at least
one of them say, oh, someone
was mentioning this fact
to me and I berated them.
So I think that
they, on that end,
are not thinking about
doing something like that.
If they were to try
to-- well, first off,
I think they're going to
be more slow to adopt this
in a commercial standpoint,
because they don't want to be
the ones running out ahead.
Right?
They already know
that they're going
to catch flak for that sort
of thing, deserved or not.
And so they're going to wait,
and they're going to see.
As to what startups
are going to do--
you know, biofuel, algae,
things outside of what
we might eat or
put in our mouths--
that's a different thing.
There is one guy who's
doing some interesting stuff
with livestock.
This is not with Cas9.
This is Scott Fahrenkrug.
He has a company called,
I think, Recombinetics.
And it turns out that this is--
For him, it's more
of a humane thing.
So it turns out that,
in the US, dairy cattle
are born with horns.
And they have to be removed.
And you can imagine that's
not a very nice process
for the animal.
So all dairy cattle in the
US have this done to them.
Whether you knew that or
not, it's really nasty,
and it's really terrible.
And the videos that he
shows are really bad.
But it turns out there's a
natural allele called "polled"
that is naturally in
the cow population.
And cows are just
not born with those.
Well, the gestation time
with cows is very, very long.
So if you try to introduce this
in all the various cow species,
it would take forever.
And so he's been able to
edit the naturally occurring
polled mutation into a
variety of founder cows.
And they're normal cows; they're
just not born with horns.
You don't have to
cut them off anymore.
And so the goal with
his company is more
to not change the way we're
eating anything but to take
a naturally observed
mutation and make it
so we don't have to do
these inhumane things.
-Thank you.
-OK.
-Hi.
I'm Jennifer Hochschild.
I'm a faculty member with
the Government department
at Harvard.
So I have a sort
of a meta meta meta
question, which is probably
too late in the afternoon.
And I don't know how anybody
could answer it, anyway.
But what I'm struck
with is the contrast
between the previous
lecture by Dr. Kaplan
and the kind of enthusiasm,
excitement, recognition
that there are deep moral,
ethical, political issues.
I mean, you guys are all very
sophisticated about this.
But his fundamental
concern is, how are we
going to avoid seriously
harming people or society
through these new techniques?
Your positions,
collectively, are, look
at all a fascinating, wonderful,
terrifically exciting things
we can do to benefit
society through all
these new techniques.
Those aren't necessarily
contradictory,
but they always tend in
different directions.
How does one think about that?
I mean, my instinct
is to say that this
is sort of characterological.
That some people
are more focused
on avoiding harm and some
people are more focused
on producing gains.
But that's probably too simple.
So is there any way to get
into that very big question
of how do we frame these issues?
-How about quick answers,
right down the row?
-I'll leave it to them.
[LAUGHTER]
-Yeah.
It's a big issue,
and it's an issue
that I've faced throughout
my clinical practice.
Because when you're
working as a gynecologist,
you're working with all
these issues all the time.
I would probably
only say two things.
The first thing
is that you can't
stop the progress of science.
You can't stop people thinking.
And if you make legislation
in one country that
stops something
being done, you'll
go through another country.
That's the way it will happen.
And that's human nature.
The way we've done
it clinically--
and I think there's a difference
between what you do it
in the laboratory, in terms
of scientific understanding,
and then introducing
it in the medical field
into clinical practice in a
way that might-- hopefully help
but theoretically
might harm people--
is how you get
that balance right.
I've always done things--
one, there's two things.
Firstly, there's
a clinical need.
So I've got patients
coming to me saying,
there's a problem here we want
you to try and solve for us.
And I have to listen to them,
because I'm a clinician.
And then the other way is
to go about it in a way that
takes the public along with it.
And it's explaining to people.
If you explain to them
what it is you're doing
and why you're doing it, and
you do all the tests you can,
they then start to see you're
not some sort of Frankenstein
monsters.
But people are just generally
trying to help people.
And we've got a responsibility--
we've got an obligation
to be responsible about it
and not to sit in ivory towers
and play around with
things, but to actually
just be open and explain
what we're doing.
And in the sort of
stuff that I've been,
there's always
been a good cause.
-I think from the standpoint
of genome editing, as least,
what I would stress is
these things are just tools.
You can use a hammer
to hit someone with,
but you can also build a house.
It doesn't mean the hammer is
bad; it's what we do with it.
And we have a choice
of what we do it.
So I think that, you
know, you could say, well,
let's not use hammers anymore.
Well, you've still
got to build houses.
Now you're building
houses with rocks.
You're smashing nails
in-- stuff like that.
So I think there's
been a lot of buzz
around Cas9 and
germ-line editing,
and that sort of thing.
And it's really more about,
what do you do with it?
Right?
It's about the biologies
that you can learn.
Maybe that just makes
me an optimist--
that I think that there's
a lot we can learn,
and there's a lot of
people that we can help.
But it's not that the tool
has any inherent good.
The good is in how you use it.
-I would also add that all of
the work you've heard today
is not done without considerable
oversight-- oversight
from funding agencies,
oversight from the institutions
that employ the
scientists, oversights
from the national
institutes of health
and other federal
regulatory elements.
And I think that the
protections are there.
They're not foolproof.
And that's why getting
you, the population, who
will potentially benefit
from this research,
and hopefully not
harm, to understand
the opportunity, the challenges,
and the ethics involved.
You all need to be engaged.
You've been fabulously
engage today.
And at this point I'm going to
let Janet Rich-Edwards close us
out today, because the hour's
late, and it's time for beer.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
-Well said!
I do want to thank
all our speakers--
this wonderful panel-- this
morning's panels and speakers--
thank all of you.
Thank our online audience.
I've just been given
the list of where people
have been logging in from.
It is all over the US,
all over the world.
Peru, Finland,
Kyrgyzstan, India.
I think every continent is
represented except Australia.
I've got to wonder
what's up with them.
So it's my charge to just
summarize, really quickly.
I've got to say, I
learned a lot today.
I think we learned a
lot about discovery.
You can feel the palpable
excitement, here.
We learned a lot, this
morning, about our history.
I learned that our
history as humans
is more of a braided stream
than the old hard tree
that I'd imagined.
I learned that we are,
today, more genetically
similar amongst ourselves
than even our ancestors were.
We have talked about
fantastic advances in biology.
There's all sorts of
stuff we didn't even
talk about, like the fact
that all women are mosaics.
We all have one of
our Xs turned off.
Or that we're actually,
humans, chimeras.
If you're a mother, you carry
the cells of your children
in your bloodstream.
If you're a twin,
you're carrying
some your twin's cells.
So there's actually things as
strange in our current biology
that we're still learning about
through some of these new tools
and some of these
fantastical future visions.
We've learned about
prevention-- how
we can prevent diseases,
such as the mitochondrial DNA
techniques we've heard about.
We've learned about
protection of innocent people,
of endangered species, even
of languages and cultures
we talked about this morning.
We've talked about new
therapies on the horizon.
The hematopoietic diseases,
those blood diseases,
HIV-- can you
imagine curing HIV?
--for ourselves.
And we've even talked about
it a bit for other species.
What could, for
example, mammoth DNA
do to help the Asian elephant?
We have a fantastic,
brand-new toolbox.
We've talked about it as swords,
scalpels, knives, scissors.
We are like three-year-olds,
running around
with these tools in our hands.
And I think there's
a lot of work
to do-- all of us, not
just the scientists,
not just the
regulators-- all of us,
to consider where we
want to take this.
I think one of the most
exciting things today
is this talk of the
power of citizen science.
We've talked about the
democratization of science,
the fact that the barriers
for doing this stuff
are coming way down.
We didn't talk so
much about the dream
or the spectre of garage labs.
It's now getting
easier and easier
to do this outside
of the institutions
that we're used to
regulating things for us.
We've talked about
needing to anticipate
the ethical and legal
issues, the importance
of public perception, and
the importance of using
careful, precise language as
we describe what we're doing.
Last, it occurred
to me today that we
are the first species that
can edit its own evolution.
This stuff is
incredibly profound.
It could take us anywhere.
And it's up to us to guide it.
I just, uh-- what did we say?
We can't stop progress, and
we can't stop people thinking.
That's true.
But I would just say let's
be sure that our intelligence
doesn't outrun our wisdom.
Thank you all very much
for a terrific day,
and we'll see you soon.
[APPLAUSE]